one of the hottest real estate markets
in the nation right now is
austin texas home prices are up more
than 18 percent
in the last year i made an influx of
tech workers from silicon valley and
other parts of california
as janet chamberlin shows us that's
creating a shortage of affordable
housing and
changing the city whose unofficial
slogan is keep austin
weird
this is just one of the finest pieces of
properties a trip down lake austin with
realtor cord shiftlet
is nothing short of jaw dropping they
could probably get
25 million for it if they let go of it
he's used to selling
high dollar luxury properties like these
but since march 2020
demand in what buyers will spend has
shocked even
him so march through june we had 19
buyers that came
that were up to 20 million we've never
seen that before
i lost count after june um and if i had
to guess i would say we had 40 buyers
that were 20 to 50 million
and everyone he says wants to live on
the lake
the capital of texas laid back and long
known for its food and music scene
has become one of the fastest growing
cities in the nation
the downtown skyline is a ballet of
cranes and new skyscrapers
tech giants like google and apple
expanding their footprint
and tesla is building a massive
manufacturing plant here
since the pandemic started city leaders
say the flow of people to austin
has turned to a flood many are from
california
like startup founder ben renema who
moved with partner craig from a one
bedroom in san francisco
how is your situation here financially
better
for you than it was in san francisco
here in austin you know for the same
price for around three thousand dollars
a month i can live in a three-bedroom
house
i have a home gym i have a home office i
have a backyard
noe elias has one too along with a
million
dollar view from his home in the
low-income neighborhood where he's lived
for decades
with rising property taxes the second
grade teacher doesn't know how long he
can afford to stay here
as working-class neighborhoods close to
downtown
are turned into high-priced housing the
city council the local government has to
really
take initiative to protect the working
families you know
like families that make less than fifty
thousand dollars a year
elias says some of the state government
and city employees
long austin's backbone are moving
outside the city
where prices are cheaper and the number
of homeless
is growing we sold that for around 4.2
million
today it would be worth double that so
that was double called an eight million
dollar home
in five years court shiftlet says even
when buyers can't afford a home they
love
it's become hard to seal the deal we had
a house school on the market last week
up near round rock
a 400-ish thousand dollar house it had
96 offers
in two days and buyers can't compete
with that i mean if you're not
all cash ready to close you're not going
to get it
i sold this lot growing pains amid a
growth spur
as the pandemic fuels a city's surge
for cbs this morning janet shamley in
austin
times in my life 36 offers that's a boom
town wow
austin texas